[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الحلقه الجديده
من مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
العالم يحتاج الى ضعف التعهدات الحاليه
للطاقه المتجدده لتحقيق المستهدفات
المناخي
[موسيقى]
وللمره الخامسه منذ ابريل اوبك تخفض
توقعتها للطلب العالمي على النفط لهذا
العام
[موسيقى]
صدر خلال مؤتمر المناخ المنعقد في شرم
الشيخ تقرير للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
المتجدده ارينا خلصا الى ان مستهدفات
الطاقات المتجدده المعلنه ضمن تعهدات دول
العالم مجتمعه لا تكفي لاحداث التحول
المطلوب في مجال الطاقه من اجل تحقيق
الهدف المناخي العالمي المتمثل في الحد من
ارتفاع حراره الارض عند درجه ونصف الدرجه
المئويه ياتي هذا على الرغم من ميثاق
جلاسكو للمناخ الصادر العام الماضي والذي
دعا الدول الى تحديث اهدافها لعام 20 30
في تعهداتها الوطنيه
فبحسب ايرينا فان الدول العالم تستهدف
الوصول الى قدره انتاجيه مركبه من الطاقات
المتجدده قدرها 5.4 تيراوات بحدود بحلول
عام 20 30 وهو ما يمثل نصف ال 10.8 تيرا
من القدره الانتاجيه المركبه المطلوبه
وفقا لسناريو ايرينا للحد من ارتفاع
الحراره عند درجه ونصف الدرجه المئويه حيث
ترى ايرينا بان تحقيق الحياد الصفري
سيتطلب مضاعفه القدره الانتاجيه المركبه
المستهدفه للطاقات المتجدده بحلول عام
2030 مقارنه بمستويات التعهدات الحاليه
وبحسب ايرينا ايضا فانه وكما في منتصف
اكتوبر الماضي فان ال 183 دوله ادخلت
مستهدفات متعلقه بالطاقات المتجدده ضمن
تعهداتها المناخيه والمعروفه باسم
المساهمات المحدده وطنيا ومن بين هذه
الدول
143 دوله وضعت ارقاما محدده لتلك
المستهدفات
108 دوله منها حددت
المستهدفاتها كحجم اضافات في الانتاج او
في قدرات الانتاج من الطاقات المتجدده في
حين 12 دوله منها فقط حدد التعهدات الخاصه
بالطاقات المتجدده كنسبه من مزيجها للطاقه
بحلول عام 2030
ومن بين المئه او من بين ال 61 دوله او 61
دوله التي حددت مستهدفات طاقاتها المتجدده
كنسبه من مزيج قطاع الكهرباء لديها 13
دوله منها فقط حددت تلك النسبه باقل من
24%
و23 دوله حددتها ما بين 25
و59%
و13 دوله منها وضعتها ما بين 60% الى 89%
في حين اثني عشر دوله حددت النسبه
المستهدفه ما بين 90 الى 100% من مزيج
الكهرباء لديها
كما ان واقع مستهدفات الطاقات المتجدده في
القطاع الخاص ليس بحال افضل بحسب تقرير
ايرينا فنحو 700 شركه من بين اكبر الفين
شركه مدرجه في العالم قامت بتمنى مستهدفات
صافي صفر او انها تنظر في تبنيها لكن
وبحسب ايرينا فان معظم تلك الشركات لم تضع
استراتيجيات او خطط عمليه للوصول الى تلك
الاهداف ما يرسم علامه استفهام كبيره حول
مائده سيتم تحقيق تلك المستهدفات فعلا ام
لا
الجدير بالذكر ان عددا متزايدا من العلماء
اقروا مؤخرا بان تباطئ العالم في اتخاذ
الاجراءات الضروريه للحد من الانبعاثات قد
جعلها هدف الحد من ارتفاع حراره الارض عند
درجه ونصف الدرجه المئويه بحلول نهايه
القرن الحالي امرا مستحيلا محذرين من ان
الاستمرار الحال على ما هو عليه قد يضيع
على العالم هدف
المئويتين ايضا
[موسيقى]
اذا بحسب ايرينا على العالم ان يضاعف
مستهدفاته من الطاقات المتجدده بحلول عام
20 30 لنبقى على سكه الدرجه ونصف الدرجه
المئويه فكيف يمكن ردم هذه الفجوه بينما
هو مطلوب وبين مخرجات السياسات الحاليه
ناقشت هذا الموضوع مع المدير التنفيذي
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه المتجدده السيد
فرانشيسكو لكاميرا حيث سالته بدايه هل لمس
خلال محادثاته في شرم الشيخ اي تاثير سلبي
للتحديات الاقتصاديه والجيو السياسيه
المستجده على الالتزام الدول المشاركه في
مؤتمر المناخ للمتابعه
جواب الفوري على سؤالك هو لا بل ان اثار
ازمه اوكرانيا وارتفاع الاسعار وكل هذه
العوامل المستجده هذه السنه تشير الى انها
عززت من الطموحات ففي الولايات المتحده
شهدنا اقرار قانوني خفض التضخم الذي
يستهدف زياده الطاقه المتجدده راينا
الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو مستهدفات جديده
الشيء نفسه يحدث في الهند وفي اليابان
ايضا لذا عندما نتحدث عن الطموحات فهي
مازالت موجوده بل يتم تعزيزها ايضا
وبالحديث عن كيفيه ترجمه تلك المستهدفات
والطموحات على الارض نرى باننا بالفعل
نتجه هذا العام الى تسجيل مستوى قياسي
جديد في حجم الطاقه المتجدده التي يتم
اضافتها والتي قد تصل الى 260 او 270 جيجا
واط لكن في الحقيقه هذه المستويات ما زالت
غير كافيه
هاو بيج اس بي كم يبلغ حجم هذه الفجوه في
الطاقات المتجدده بحلول عام 2030 في ضوء
النزعات الحاليه والسياسات القائمه اليوم
فيما يخص نشر وتركيب الطاقات المتجدده
اولا في تقريرنا الاخير نشير الى ان
المستهدفات المعلنه ضمن المساهمات المحدده
والوطنيه للدول عليها ان تتضاعف حتى يكون
لدينا ما يلزمنا بحلول عام 2030 لكي نحقق
المستهدفات المناخيه وبالارقام فانه على
العالم ان يضاعف حجم الطاقات المتجدده
المركبه بنحوي ثلاثه اضعاف بحلول عام 2030
بالتالي صحيح اننا نحقق مستويات قياسيه
جديده في الطاقات المتجدده بالنمو سنويا
يتراوحما بين خمسه الى 10% لكن علينا
مضاعفه هذا النمو ثلاث مرات وهذا تغير ضخم
علينا ان نحدثه اذا ما اردنا ان يبقى
القطار على كانت الحد من ارتفاع درجه
حراره الارض عند درجه ونصف الدرجه مئويه
بعد سننتقل من الطموحات الى التنفيذ
التنفيذ يحتاج الى تمويل ونحن نلتقي اليوم
في مؤتمر المناخ في يوم التمويل هل تلمس
فعلا زياده في رغبه القطاع الخاص والبنوك
في تمويل مشاريع الطاقات المتجدده في
الدول الناميه اما انه ما زالوا يضعون
شروطا لتخفيف المخاطر ويطالبون حكومات
الدول الناميه بالمشاركه بالتمويل ايضا
هذا السؤال
على عناصر متعدده اولا علينا ان نعيم
مساله مهمه جدا
هذه المساله تحدثنا عنها كثيرا في الايام
الاخيره هنا وهي ضروره اعاده كتابه اسس
التعامل الدولي من اجل زياده الاستثمارات
كما قلته في جلسه الهيدروجين الاخضر هنا
في شرم الشيخ علينا تشكيله سرديه جديده
حيث يجب علينا تشييد البنى التحتيه
الضروريه لمنظومه الطاقه الجديده لان
المنظومه القديمه للطاقه كانت تعتمد على
بناء تحتيه قائمه فكيف نطالب اليوم
افريقيا بزياده طاقتها المتجدده وهي لا
تملك البنيه التحتيه الضروريه لذلك وكيف
يمكن لنا ان نرفع الاستثمارات اذا لم يكن
لدينا البنيه التحتيه القانونيه اللازمه
كيف يمكن زياده الاستثمارات اذا لم نبني
ونعزز قدره تلك الدول وبالتالي علينا
اعاده هيكله اسس التعاون الدولي ماذا يعني
ان الطالب افريقيا بحفظ انبعاثاتها وهي
مسؤوله فقط عن اثنين في المئه من اجمالهم
بعثات العالم من ثاني اكسيد الكربون علينا
ان نشيد القطاع الصناعي الاخضر ونطوره في
تلك الدول حتى يتسنى لها ان تكون لاعبا
فعالا في سلسله امدادات البطاريات
والتخزين فكل عناصر الطاقات المتجدده يمكن
ان يتم تصنيعها في افريقيا وفي جنوب شرق
اسيا اذا من المهم علينا ان نعيد صياغه
التعاون الدولي اذا ما اردنا فعلا زياده
الاستثمارات على الارض
تخص الطاقات المتجدده في مساهماتها
المناخيه المحدده الوطنيه ولكن هل ترى اي
عيوب او نقص في طريقه تصميم تلك
المستهدفات المتعلقه بالطاقات المتجدده
نعاني من مستوى الطموح المطلوب فاذا ما
حصرنا نقاشنا ضمن اطار تقرير هيئه
الحكوميه الدوليه المعنيه بتغير المناخ
وضمن ما علينا ان نصل اليه بحلول عام 2030
فعلينا مضاعفه مستهدفاتنا المعلنه اليوم
هذا يعني رفع سقف طموحنا وهذا يترجم
بمضاعفه حجم الطاقات المتجدده التي يتم
تركيبها ثلاثه اضعاف اما بالنسبه
للمتطلبات كل عناصر تحول الطاقه فلذلك
يستوجب زياده حجم الاستثمارات الى خمسه
ترينات و700 مليار دولار بحلول عام 2030
وهذه مهمه صعبه للغايه لكن لننتبه فان هدف
الدرجه ونصف الدرجه المئويه يكاد يتلاشى
واذا لم نتفاعل مع هذا الامر فحتى هدفوا
الدرجتين مئويتين معرض للخطر ايضا
الاقتصادي الراهن للمستويات التضخم مرتفعه
وتصاعد في نسب الفائده قد تبدا في الضغط
على مشاريع الطاقات المتجدده وتمويلاتها
خاصه في الدول الاقل
وما بين المدى المتوسط الى البعيد فالازمه
الحاليه ستسرع بلا شك من وتيره التحول على
الاجل البعيد ولكن حتى على الاجر القصير
الازمه اليوم تزيد الفارق السعري ما بين
كل فتت الطاقات المتجدده
ملفه الوقود الاحفوري فتكلفه الغاز اليوم
تصل الى قرابه 10 اضعاف كلفه الطاقات
المتجدده ولكن على الاجر القصير سنجد هناك
عاملان متضادان الاول وان كل فتت طاقات
المتجدده تصبح اكثر تنافسيا اما الاخر فهو
ارتفاعه كلفه التمويل وتقطع سلاسل الامداد
لذا قد نواجه بعض التحديات على الامد
القصير لكن على المدى المتوسط والبعيد فان
عمليه التحول تتسارع لكن هذا لا يعني ان
هذا التسارع بوتيرته الحاليه سيكون كافيا
لان نتماشى مع مسدسات اتفاقيه باريس
للمناخ
[موسيقى]
فاصل القصير مشاهدينا نتابع بعده في
مستقبل الطاقه
قابل خاصه مع لورينزو سيمونالي رئيس مجلس
الاداره والرئيس التنفيذي لشركه الخدمات
النفطيه بيكه هيوس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد خفضت اوبك تقديراتها
للطلب العالمي على النفط في عام 20 22
للمره الخامسه منذ ابريل الماضي التقديرات
الجديده تشير الى نمو طلب بمليونين و550
الف برميل يوميا هذا العام بما يقل بمائه
الف برميل يوميا عن التوقعات السابقه كما
خفضت لمنظمه توقعتها للطلب في العام
المقبل ب 100,000 برميل ايضا الى مليونين
ومئتين 240,000 برميل يوميا
انتاج الدول الاعضاء في اوبك انخفض في
اكتوبر باكثر من 200,000 برميل يوميا وهو
رقم يفوق التخفيض الذي قراراته اوبن بلس
للانتاج في اكتوبر بواقع مئه الف بالمئه
في المقابل يشير تقرير اوبك الى ان
المعروض تفوق على الطلب في السوق النفطيه
بنحو 200.000 برميل يوميا في الربع الثاني
من هذا العام وبنحو من مليون ومئه يوميا
في الربع الثالث ولهذا السبب سجلت مخسولات
النفط التجاريه لدى مجموعه دول او اي سي
دي زياده بنحو 13 مليون برميل في شهر
سبتمبر لكنها ضلت ادنى من متوسط السنوات
الخمس الماضيه بنحوي 200 مليون برميل
بالطبع فان اوبيك تبقى على حذر من تباطؤ
الاقتصاد العالمي ومخاوف الركود التي تهدد
الاقتصادات الكبرى وهذا ما يفسر قرار اوبك
بلس في اجتماعي الاخير افضل انتاج في
نوفمبر بمليوني برميل يوميا من الحصص
الرسميه للدول الاعضاء لكن طبعا هذا الخفض
لا يتجاوز مليون برميل يوميا من الانتاج
الفعلي الذي هو اقل من الحصص الرسميه
[موسيقى]
بالرغم من تخفيض اوبك لتوقعاتها لنمو
الطلب هذا العام والعام المقبل ما زال
العالم يحتاج الى زياده
استثماراته في استكشاف واستخراج النفط
والغاز لتلبيه الطلب المتنامي وتعويض
الانخفاض الطبيعي في انتاج الحقول القائمه
ولكن هل ستتركز تلك الاستثمارات في
المشاريع ذات الدوره قصيره الاجل المعروفه
بالشوعه سايكل بروجيكس ام ان ازمه الطاقه
الحاليه قد تدفع رؤوس الاموال نحو مشاريع
ذات الدورات الاطول اجلا هذه الامور
وغيرها كانت محور حديثي مع رئيس شركه
الخدمات النفطيه في بيكره هيروز السيد
لورانسو سيمولالي
اهلا بك لورانسو وشكرا على انضمامك لنا هل
ستوجب ازمه الطاقه الحاليه زياده في
استثمارات المنبع في النفط والغاز خلال
السنوات القليله المقبله وما هو نطاق
الاستثمار المتوقع مقارنه بالسنوات
الاخيره
ولكن لورينزو ما هو نوع المشاريع التي
ستجذب تلك الاستثمارات المتوقعه التي
تحدثت عنها هل ستبقى الاستثمارات تفضل
المشاريع ذات الدوره الاستثماريه قصيره
الاجل كما شاهدنا في السنوات الاخيره اما
ان هذا قابل للتغيير في رايك
اي تنكتب
لنتحدث الان عن نظرتك لاداء اسواق النفط
خلال العام المقبل تحديدا خاصه في ضوء
المخاوف المتزايده من الركود الاقتصاديه
العالمي واثره على الطلب على النفط
س
مان 4
ميسي
هذا العام لم يترجم بعد الى زياده في حجم
وعدد القرارات الاستثماريه النهائيه في
مشاريع الغاز المسال على الاقل بحسب ما
كان مامولا من البعض وخاصه في الولايات
المتحده ما رايك مما يحدث في هذا المجال
افراديه
مستر بين
تم مؤخرا اعاده هيكله شركه بيكر هيوز
وتقسيمها حول نشاطين رئيسيين حدثنا اكثر
عن هذه الخطه الاستراتيجيه لورينزو
واثارها على اعمالكم
ريف بروفايلند
[موسيقى]
الحلقه مستقبل الطاقه للمزيد دائما
تابعونا على تويتر الاستماع
[موسيقى]